you were on a soundstage with I think
the first thing was a black box where
you have had your actors correct yes
okay and this wasn't just again I'm
trying to get everybody up to speed here
because I'm want to know why I can't
think in hell sure sure so you know it
it gets confusing when we talk about the
particulars oh right but I think the the
overarching vision for what we thought
we we should do here was you know the
task at hand was to make this movie
appear to be a live-action film right
because the Disney Animated Classics
were being remade as live-action filmed
but clearly we weren't going to be doing
live-action singing lions so that became
the the the beginning of and we had just
Rob and I had just worked on the Jungle
Book and we learned a lot on that and
there was some consumer facing VR
hardware that had come out towards the
end of that and we started messing
around with what you could do with this
essentially video game technology and
uploading files that we would use in
digital animation into VR and be able to
actually walk around and we thought wow
this is really interesting if we were to
do if we were starting a jungle book we
would be using this instead of the
traditional old motion capture gear that
we were inheriting for the most part
without much change since like avatar
was 10 years earlier and then when the
idea of doing Lion King came up and
applying this technology to that we
thought it's the perfect way to take you
know animated performances and and what
would have normally been done with the
animation pipeline and use a live-action
crew to help make it feel like we were
seeing something that was more real
right so that led to as you're saying
the black box theater so they did
photography and just to be clear they
were doing moving photography but that
was not plates
those aren't there's only one
live-action one purely live-action shot
in there which is the very first shot of
the sunrise right everything else was
created by CG artists digital artists
every performance was done by animators
so if you look at the end credits
we have our live-action crew but also
everything that you would see associated
with like a Pixar film as well so a lot
of artists work went into it in order to
be made to look invisible oh you
actually reverse the process instead of
doing a performance capture of the
actors you were doing kind of reference
footage even performance capture of the
cameras right so everything every animal
was keyframe animated like they would
have done for Bambi and instead of doing
like what Rango did which was have just
cameras as reference we actually encoded
all of the cam work that Kaleb and Rob
were doing so it started with me with
the actors in not at music stands if we
could ever help and have them in a black
box theater with just some video
reference for the animators and usable
sound and I would have them improv
overlap and everything that was
dictating the performance was coming
from them the animators would then get
that Andy Jones would get that right do
animation of all the action of the film
and then we would be using VR to scout
the locations that were built based on
all their reference and uploaded
digitally and so in scouting which is
when this process was most valuable six
of us all the department heads a
live-action crew would be in there
together
scouting except instead of looking at a
little screen we would walk around and
we would talk like we were on a tech
Scout I was lucky because I came in
after the daunting decision that John
and Rob made that they could actually
pull this off and I just had to you know
be put into this real world that Rob and
the people from magno pass and created
all these tools that are exactly like
the tools I've always used I mean
they're you know dollies cranes and you
know gear heads and I had to camera and
I had I could set any lens I wanted and
everything and then you know the
advantage obviously is that I could move
the Sun around and change the lighting
and we could pick one of 350 skies we
had in our library and you know and
initially you know when they would do
the the animation sometimes in the early
stages you know some of the the sets
weren't quite finished and you know an
animal would suddenly walk through a
rock or something like
dad and but you know after about the
first month or two the animation got
really sophisticated to the point where
you really could read the emotions and
everything and you could make all the
decisions that you would make when
you're making a regular movie and then
we also had a certain amount of freedom
to where any one of the tools that we
have whether it was a gear head or a
fluid head or dolly or whatever could be
repurposed to do something else and you
could actually hook a lion up to it and
speed him up slightly if they were too
lined up and you wanted one slightly
ahead of the other you could just put
that movement on a dolly as well and so
you know it became really inventive I
mean we just started you know it was it
started out very conventionally and we
kept thinking that well we have a dolly
grip but but we had a regular grip doing
it but you know he wasn't really a dolly
grip so we ended up being in a real
dolly grip who's used to moving with
animals and then you know the the
computer would follow the focus and you
know that never felt right to me so I
brought in my regular first assist and
then he followed focus because there's a
certain art to that to way you move into
something and the speed and the attack
in which it takes its you know it's you
know the whole thing and so it gives it
a feeling that there's somebody behind
the camera watching the way you watch a
movie there's a certain point when
you're watching when your attention goes
from one thing to another and that's
when you know a really good camera
operator or an assistant you know draws
your eye to something and that was all
built into it because of you know John
and and Rob having the confidence that
they could actually pull this off which
is pretty thank God I didn't make that
because I started getting worried at
various times along the way so Rob
talked a little bit about that decision
in your conversation with John as far as
what tools that you knew what he was
going for and and you're you're working
together to come up with this system
which is almost a flipside of what had
been done in the past if I'm
understanding correctly yeah it's a bit
of a flip side I think I was hired
because I was the king of human
perfection and that's why John picked me
I think well
actually it's what you really want in
something is to remind you of films
you've seen before and that quality that
is intangible and it part of it is the
there's a human operator behind the the
lens being the audience shifting focus
when you need to shift focus shifting
focus in the scene and you do that and
you have to block it out for these
moments so the idea what we did on
Jungle Book is that we had a portal into
the virtual world but not walk around in
it and it changes as soon as you put the
goggles on you see in three dimensions
when you take a step it takes a step and
it's all you know there's no latency
whatsoever so you feel and you get used
to it very quickly and you start
becoming a director and a cameraman and
and and and the rest because you go you
walk over to the better shot or the one
that's more interesting and so it
intangibly
has everything you've ever done before
in your live-action life is transmuted
into this particular way so what John
wanted to do and I wanted to do is to
totally lean into the analog nature of
shooting and those and that is live
input and you're gonna make a decision
based on what you're seeing and you may
alter it when something happens that you
were not expecting and then don't get
rid of it
don't perfect it in live-action terms
you always try to make everything
perfect the dollar move has to be
perfect the focus has to be perfect and
it just never is it's as close as you
can get in the computer everything is
perfect but you don't want it because it
sterilizes the the scene and all that
stuff so everything and you know what we
reached a point where we were even
mimicking a Steadicam and that was like
screw it
get a Steadicam operator because if he
wanted to look like a Steadicam operator
was operating it get a Steadicam
operator
and it was that simple and so that the
the part of what we leaned into is we
cannot improve on the hundred years of
moviemaking it just can't be done no
matter how you shake it you need to
rehearse you need to get live input
actors and directors and cameramen and
production designers look at something
go oh I have a better idea let's do this
and you cannot and you do take after
take until you hit the movie till like
that goes in the film the other part of
this is the voices and and I know that
traditionally in animation like you say
they were lockdown stands and sometimes
individual recordings of individual
actors I know you
Billy and Seth record together I don't
know if that happened with other actors
or not but there was also the ability to
move and to allow them to feel more a
part of a body performance along with
their voice performing yeah I mean I've
always liked motion captures very good
for certain things but I found that the
most useful part of motion capture if
you were translating it to a non
anthropomorphic animal was mostly that
you're inheriting the choices that the
actors are making so so in a traditional
animated film you would have a voice
performance and maybe they would look at
you know like from Robin Williams it's
you know you see his they would
videotape him and clearly the animators
were inspired by that or or Gollum you
know that was pre motion capture andy
serkis would make certain choices and
the animators would keyframe matching in
with that but for the most part what
you'll see if you go to an animation
house is they'll listen to the voices
and I'll have a mirror next to the next
to their monitor and they'll make faces
and you'll get performances that feel
fine and animation but it's very
exaggerated if you saw it in a
live-action film and so I wanted to
eliminate the going the the temptation
to go bigger with their voice or with
their performance and I wanted all the
timing and overlapping that you don't
get when you're doing it alone and we
try to do it with as many actors as we
could we would do pickups later at music
stands or if people like Donald Glover
for some of the sessions was doing solo
in in London so we'd get him and Chu
hotel together in London so we did
everything we could but but under the
best circumstances we would have it
basically look at a theatre performance
we would be in a black box theater
everything would be miked and I would
have them and then I could let them
improv and we could really have a lot of
fun you know there weren't that many
areas with a movie like Lion King where
you could take liberties without
undermining people's expectations of the
title the comedy team won in Pumbaa
things like that where we felt that we
had some some free Running Room we went
crazy with it the takeaway is something
that really puts the technology on a on
a pedestal and shows the state of the
art of what could be
because as you point out it's not the
computers doing it this is the most
handmade movie I've ever worked on and
these tools that they have available
allow the artist to hand paint every
frame every performance every facial
expression every blade of grass every
environment is built it is a
hand-painted tile in a big mosaic and so
what I'm most proud of is how the whole
team came together to present this thing
that feels seamless and allows you to
ride the same emotional journey the
original did but presenting in a
different way that hopefully doesn't
feel redundant to the original
congratulations on balancing out the art
in the science